I'm Darren George, and I grow
and restore bonsai trees.
I'm going to walk you through
how I restore an overgrown bonsai tree.
The tree that I'm working on
today is called cotoneaster.
This particular tree was started
by a bonsai professional
up north in England
and came into my possession
when the previous owner
decided to give up bonsai
and had let the tree deteriorate somewhat.
The tree has fallen into disrepair.
It has several overgrown branches,
and there are also a number of branches
that have completely died.
The deadwood is rotting
and falling away from the tree.
The first step in
restoring this bonsai tree
is going to be cleaning
out the massive branches
so that I can see the underlying
structure of the tree.
I'm going to remove any dead pieces
and generally thin out the
massive leaves and twigs.
Now I can see what's going
on inside of the canopy.
I can see that there
are a couple of branches
that are growing from the same position.
They're crowding each other out
and making the tree look quite messy
and spoiling the flow of the design.
So I'm going to select one or two branches
to completely remove to open up some space
to ensure the health of
the branches that remain,
and also create a more open
and rounded feel to the canopy.
Where I am removing a larger branch,
I'm going to use a special
putty that we call Cut Paste.
The Cut Paste helps the wound heal
much faster than it ordinarily would
and prevents rot and bacteria setting in.
Where I've created some
space in the canopy,
I'm going to use some wire to reposition
a couple of the remaining branches,
so that we've got quite a nice,
even distribution of
foliage around the tree,
and remove any large gaps in the canopy.
And once they're all in position,
the work for this moment is complete,
and I can allow the tree to respond
and grow into the new shape.
Several months later in the spring,
and the state of the deadwood
is really starting to bother me.
The longer I leave it,
the more it's going to deteriorate,
so I'd like to get the
deadwood treated and hardened.
Before I apply the
treatment to the deadwood,
I have to ensure that the
deadwood is thoroughly dry.
I keep it out of the elements,
under shelter, so that it can dry out.
I'm using a two-part epoxy resin.
It has a solvent mixed in with it
that encourages the resin
to penetrate the soft deadwood
so that the epoxy can harden
further into the core of the wood
and hopefully allow it to last longer.
I'm applying the epoxy
resin to the deadwood
as carefully as I can, trying to ensure
not to get it on the
live wood or on the soil.
I'm going to let it dry
for a couple of days.
Now that the epoxy is completely dry,
I'm rigorously brushing it
to take the sheen off
the surface of the wood.
I really want it to look
old and sun-bleached
rather than shiny and new.
So using a steel brush,
it roughs up the surface
and takes that reflection off the wood.
After a long and hot summer,
this tree has absolutely
exploded with growth.
The branches are super long, super thick,
and really, really healthy.
Once again, I need to come along,
I need to cut back these branches
to regain the shape of the canopy.
I'm also checking for any opportunities
to reposition any branches
that aren't in the ideal locations.
So with all these really long shoots
that have grown over summer,
I'm going to trim them back
to regain the silhouette.
And it also gives me another opportunity
to apply some wire to reposition
any new branches that have developed since
and continue filling in the tree's crown.
Now, with all the watering
that I've been doing
over the hot summer,
we've got some hard-water stains built up
around the base of the tree,
on the bottom of the trunk,
and on some of the roots
on the soil surface.
I'm using a toothbrush and vinegar
to try and dissolve and scrub off
some of that white calcium buildup.
On the soil surface,
there are some undissolved
fertilizer pellets.
I'll quickly brush those off
to reveal the green moss underneath.
And that concludes the work on this tree.
Now I'm done with this bonsai.
I'm really excited to see how it responds
and continue working with it
as it grows into the future.